you run this website it's one of the
largest now what's the claim it's the
largest men's interest magazine
independent we say independent it's
where you know we're not owned by a
corporation so it's just just me and my
wife who run the show
so yeah largest independent men's
website because you know those
corporations we got a co similar
direction yeah yeah watch out
corporations man by the way just to make
sure this is not at all an endorsement
of any of my views or political
standings that Brett is on he just
happens to be nice gentlemen but then
again we've also had actual terrorists
on the show Brett so doesn't mean we
endorse the actual terrorism now Art of
Manliness what's funny about it is that
it seems to be an actual site where men
actually want to hang out there and read
it I'm sure you know about the big scam
with a lot of the men's interest
magazines where they just buy up
subscriptions and not many people
actually read it but you guys actually
have a significant readership and return
readership yeah we have we've developed
a really passionate following because
our goal from the get-go has just been
to help men become better men in all
aspects of their life and as a result of
them you know a lot of our content is
just problem driven driven think about
the problems that guys have and try to
write content that will help them and
it's amazing Steven the letters that
I've gotten over the years I mean I get
I get actual handwritten letters in the
mailbox that's something we advocate on
site you know bringing back the the art
of the handwritten letter sure but yeah
I mean people telling us how the site
has changed their life it's helped their
marriage I've had one guy say tell us
the story about how the Art of Manliness
led to him finding his wife it's a
really cool story he you basically read
a post and went and there's this girl
that he was very you know he was
interested in and ended up marrying her
and that's the Art of Manliness brought
them together well that takes me to an
important question I have for you sure
and it's kind of a it's kind of a social
question so it could be a long answer
but I definitely do feel like it's
speaking with a lot of young men out
there there is more confusion and a lot
of young men feel more conflicted about
what it is to be a man in today's
society
than ever and you get some pushback
obviously from feminism and from just
the way society is sort of you know now
the big messages your male priviledge is
showing so sometimes men feel inherently
guilty have you noticed when you get
these handwritten letters back that some
men just feel a little conflicted about
who they should really be in modern
America well the thing we get is that
the site has helped them feel good about
being a man right um
and the truth is yeah there is a lot of
confusion about what it means to be a
man attain society and that's a complex
reason why that is a lot of people want
to find simple answers that oh it's
feminism or it's this but this is
something that we've been dealing with
in America since its founding
masculinity has always been debated what
it means to be a man and you know in
recent years there's been an uptick and
this sort of like what this you know
this conversation right with all the big
media outlets about you know what does
it mean to be a man today and it what's
interesting but you know because of the
sight I've had the opportunity to do a
lot of research about the history of
masculinity in America this this
conversation that we're having is pretty
much similar to a conversation that
happened in America at the turn of the
night or a turn of the 20th century
right because right now the conversation
is well masculinity is obsolete because
a nice mug it is a nice mug for those
looks really it's the Art of Manliness
the Art of Manliness mug no yeah so the
conversation now is that masculinity is
obsolete because we're moving into an
information economy so right uh you know
we don't need men to be big and strong
and we don't need a manual blue collar
workforce they need to be more soft and
sensitive and cetera um which is the
others there's some truth to that that's
where the economy is going but what's
interesting is that at the turn of the
20th century like late 19th century
there was a similar conversation except
that the instead of moving to an
information economy
the argument was that men are becoming
obsolete because we are in a dust
realized nation right and machines are
replacing men and you know a lot of our
American folk tales that we have like
Paul Bunyan
uh John Henry right feeling about it
it's about man versus
I was gonna say it's about cool hats and
will happen gear that could be but I
don't know if you know this it's also
funny that you talk about this we've
we've had a guest on before bill Whittle
who talks about how actually the
economic conversation mirrors that
because as we transition from
agricultural to industrial right now of
a sudden you have everyone who had their
own plot of land with you know in an
agricultural society agrarian I believe
the term area I live in school and then
all of a sudden you've moved to there
are a few wealthy people the people who
own these industries and factories and
you create a working class whereas now
with the internet economically we're
returning to that same conversation
where people can have their own plot of
digital land and wealth effectively can
be more distributed the kind of theory
is you're going to have fewer
billionaires but far more people making
good six-figure incomes online
independently so it's maybe kind of the
same thing except where we're talking
about man parts
we're going back to that yeah and what's
interesting too is that you know in
recent years has been sort of like this
minnesota i guess you call like where
the whole you know men guys are growing
beards again they're you know we're in
flannel they're going camping and
there's all these lifestyle sites
dedicated to men right so being a man is
awesome right all these businesses have
popped up around that time was funny is
that around the late 19th century when
they were having this sort of
conversation about what it means to be a
man there really was like this
renaissance and masculine at the time
too you know a lot of the the ideas and
I guess archetypes of masculinity we
have in America today began in the 19th
century boxing became huge in America at
this time and John L Sullivan the guy
who sort of the boxer guide it's on the
top of the Art of Manliness and Hobart
mustache like he was a just a star like
everyone just obsessed about him
baseball became huge football became
huge because these were seen as outlets
where men could show off their strength
or physical strength and a world that no
longer really needed men because of
machines so as an opportunity for men to
display that yeah so yeah it's really
I'm saying that we're the same sort of
thing you're seeing the same sort of
thing happened today as well
MMA is becoming really popular amongst
you know entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley
types
CrossFit is huge where it's basically
you're these mud runs and like GORUCK
challenges where you know we live in a
world where you know it's cushy you
don't need you don't have to fear for
your life you don't really have to work
hard to make a living your food comes
wrapped up in you know plastic at the
grocery store yeah and so I think we're
finding trying to find ways where we
could tap into sort of this primal
masculine t-that's within us that we
want to get in touch with so we do hard
things we try to make ourselves suffer
uh sort of a tap into that primal
masculinity that we have in rainiest
life the strenuous yeah well there's
another there's another example we have
19th century Teddy Roosevelt in his
strenuous life you know yet to be the
doer of Deeds um well that's a great
example if you read a story to a lot of
people they don't know enough about the
man you know he was sickly he was his
kid who really wasn't you know the star
athlete probably wouldn't pick last for
gym class but it's that principle what's
so funny to you bring me to this this
point I was talking about with my wife
you nowadays we create sort of these
false male archetypes right like well
you're the dumb jock you're the center
of one but the fact is if you look at
great leaders who are great
intellectuals right there were fantastic
thinkers or or spiritualists all of them
believed that there was a finical up as
a pinnacle a physical manifestation of
that discipline they believed in the
strenuous life hey go out and do
something hard physically everyday
because mentally that disciplines you it
wasn't one or the other if you read
Roosevelt was a very creative thinker
could but you know he'd be a little goth
kid today writing poems I mean would
make fun of and then he'd kick the crap
out of you yeah exactly they combine
brains and bronze right and something we
kind of we talk about a lot on the site
lots of great thinkers like you go back
to the ancient Greeks they thought the
same way what it meant to be a man was
combining the physical attributes but
also with these sort of contemplative
thinking and they they believed like you
said that you know doing hard things
physically working hard physically
showing physical courage
transferred itself over to the the
political or moral or spiritual life
they also did some pretty weird stuff
the Greeks it is some weird stuff
with stuff but they'd probably say the
same thing about us you know what though
I don't want YouTube cat sand that's
true stuff I don't know they would say
hey that cat playing the piano is weird
I'd be like that's we're having an
11-year old boy and the sides kind of
weird so I know you're right and it's
funny so now there's sort of this I I
guess I'm trying to think of a polite
way to put it because I don't want to
bring feminism to the picture sort of a
neo androgynous view let's put it that
way where there's this idea that well
you know this false sense of machismo is
what men are and so a lot of people have
condemned men for something that's a
pretty recent right sort of picture of a
man that wasn't it for a long time like
you're talking about the Greeks the
Romans our founding fathers creative
thinkers intellectuals who also you know
we're wheeled in axes in stomping
stomping heads yeah they're the warrior
philosophers yeah you're right a lot of
the arguments against masculinity often
use sort of a straw man hmm
and yeah they create like that they go
for the most extreme version of
masculinity or what some people would
call hyper masculinity right and der I
mean I mean I to the point like yeah
that's that type of masculinity is not
that great it's not conducive to good
Society doesn't help us become a better
people but I think for the most part
most men I think inherently get what it
means to be a good man in their lives
they can look to whether it be their
father or a grandfather or even mentors
they had in high school so yeah I mean I
don't I mean that's the funny thing even
though we're called the Art of Manliness
we don't get into a lot of debates like
people don't want to go there it is an
incredibly positive atmosphere below
that because anywhere else in the
internet we've talked about this with
guests after guests you have about the
first five posts the grace posts and
then it just devolves into the worst
that humanity has to offer give like the
Olive Garden I love olive garden salad
and breadsticks I agree they are good
and then some guy is talking about how
he's going to have a gang knock off your
mother because they're you wouldn't know
a good breadstick if it you know [ __ ]
you in the posterior and it was like it
happened so quickly your site is one of
the few exceptions almost to the point
that it's like Pleasantville where
people are too nice where I'm like
someone just
you know yell something anti-semitic or
something that's gonna hurt somebody's
feelings this isn't the internet anymore
no I mean we've worked really hard
developed at that culture I guess on the
site right through our content and as we
moderate the comments because you know
the site isn't like it's my home I
joined like that and I wouldn't let some
gay who come into my house and just say
do whatever they want to it I'd kicked
them out or even do worse things so I
treat my website the same way so yeah I
hope you're invited to come in but
you're the rules if you don't play by
the rules well you can go there's other
places you can hang out on the internet
right um but we try to keep it positive
what's funny you know your audience with
that I think and I think that like we've
talked about in the same sort of sensor
these sort of false male archetypes that
were pushed onto people there's this
false idea of men's interests and you
know my friend Greg Gutfeld who actually
hosts there in Fox News he was the
editor at Men's Health and mhm he was
fired actually for men's health because
he wrote an article on the positive
attributes of tobacco and now we know it
to be true that it can fight Alzheimer's
and I wasn't saying go light up but this
was just very controversial right you
could never write that in Men's Health
magazine
nicotine does that yeah yeah that's in
the studies yeah I don't advise that
anyone smokes by the way but oh he let
us in on the secret you know and he's
talked about this openly says a lot of
people don't really read these magazines
they buy up subscriptions so they can
sell ad space and he worked there he's
the readership is incredibly low and I
thought you know what that's funny
that's that that's probably pretty true
because you're talking about a magazine
if you open it up let's say you just
open up one of the top male magazines
right now right it'll be one page
yachting a tire what to wear to your
yacht party then next page evil rich
people but you were just appealing to
yachting attire in the next page you
know is some basically something that
would make penthouse letters from the
70s blush just incredibly graphic I'm
going a lot of people wouldn't want to
read this mix of material it turns out
they don't and I get the sense that from
your site a lot of men are filling this
void of oh it's a place I can go where
there's this they're pragmatic pieces
that help me become a better man yeah
it's funny you mentioned the men's
magazines in the men's health I mean
that's actually what it's
The Art of Manliness here's the story of
the genesis of The Art of Manliness I
was in a bookstore one night during law
school killing time went to the men's
interest section in the magazine section
it was looking at the headlines
something I do all the time and I
remember just sitting there looking at
the headlines on these magazines and
just realizing that my gosh every month
it's the same thing it's like how to get
six-pack ABS right how negative a Cosmo
s sex tips right he ins you need to try
you know the the ten thousand dollar
suit you need to wear and you need two
six-packs apps to try those uh try those
sex positions try this and you actually
I think one time I saw like eight pack
abs like wow there's eight pack abs okay
yeah it's called the famine victim look
the famine victim look and I just
realize like you know what this stuff
does does not this doesn't resonate with
me like this doesn't like to me doesn't
tell me like this doesn't mean like to
me this isn't say masculine he doesn't
say manhood no so I thought of like what
it meant to be a good man says D bad
Anna Lee yeah it is it is a really tough
time I know people say you have no idea
what it is you're men of women's rights
get mad you and say men's rights or
anything I'm not talking about men's
rights but I'm talking about young men
you know I have a pretty young demo for
a more sort of right-leaning political
website we don't do quite as well as you
but we do well and I get a lot of emails
we just had Gary Wilson for example on
where we talked about you know your
brain on porn and actually I think I'd
come across him on on your site or Rob
wolf was a friend of mine who covered
his stuff too and we just get emails
from young men saying I just I just fell
into this no one told me about these
these pitfalls I mean I'm so conflicted
now I don't know who to talk to about
this and that's just a microcosm
pornography but I can imagine now and
when you have people telling men this is
what they're being taught on campus that
you are guilty by birth and a lot of
these men are feminists or a lot of
these men certainly wouldn't want to
have privilege thrust upon them it
creates a sense of of needless guilt
because I haven't done anything wrong
and that's got to be tough to deal with
today as a young teenager yeah I can
imagine
and you're right like we don't really do
a good job in our country or a culture
of hell
young men feel good about themselves and
the result is you know you can look at
the statistics on how young men are
doing right suicide is high amongst
young men unemployment high college
attendance is lower
you know the pornography thing is part
of it I mean it's it's just it's really
dismal and it's funny I was actually
talking to a gal you see on my podcast
student she's a PhD in psychology and
she you know she's a self-described
feminist but she even does edge like we
we make young men feel horrible about
themselves sure and we've gotten and we
were bearing the the fruits of that now
yeah
and there was a time in our in our
country where there was a little bit
more mentoring that when what took place
in a young man's life either through
their father or their uncle was there
their grandfather they were there to
teach them how to be a man and you have
a lot of young men today who are growing
up either in single mother homes they
don't there's no not a father and that
in the picture worrying that even if dad
is around right he might be really busy
with work sure he has to put in the long
hours at the office in order to provide
the lifestyle that you know he wants to
give to his family right and so he never
has the time to teach his kid like how
to shave and like people think like oh
how does she like teaching what's that
gonna do to help your son it you know
yeah everyone had a shave but there's
there's more that goes on in that that
process try because it shows like you
know the kid knows like my dad cares
about me right and he wants he wants the
best for me and then just spending time
with their kids like you conversations
come up sort of spontaneously where you
can talk to your son or talk to your
grandson or talk to and I feel like what
it means to be a good man and that's not
happening for one that's what you have
all this confusion where you have guys
who are going to the internet to find
out is Lauren you just said something
that was like a trigger word for me
trigger phrase trigger trigger warning
yeah no they just said you said young
men are trying to go to the Internet yes
yeah you have you have young men who
don't have a father don't have a grant I
don't a male mentor right on showing
them how I mean what it means to be a
man what what you need to do to be a
good man so they go the internet and you
know there's not I mean
you're basically you know who knows what
they're learning there and so they you
know some they might pick up like this
sort of like a lot of a really popular
things like the pickup artist community
is really popular online and it's just
all about you know okay to be a man yeah
I get all these notches on your belt
right and that's how they define
masculinity and so you get these guys in
this trap whether you know they fork
over a lot of money to learn how to pick
up women and then they're not successful
and then they just feel like crap
because man what means if being a man
means like you have to get it have sex
as many women as possible I'm a failure
as a man so I suck as a man right so you
get these very one-dimensional ideas of
masculinity and it's unfortunate and and
that's the minority though it's
important for people to note because
you'll have people let's say you know
feminists right now we'll hear Art of
Manliness write a neo feminist let's say
likely or Keith who we had on right away
will be upset because they'll attribute
that minority male culture that minority
sorry of mail called not saying male
minorities let me clarify that a small
contingency of male culture who are just
saying what it means to be a man is not
just on my belt in what you offer young
men is antithetical to that but it gets
lumped into the same category as the
essence of man sure and that's a
terrible mischaracterization to make
well I understand I mean it's just it's
easy thinking right to make
generalizations like that so I
understand why it why it happens but
yeah I mean our our goal is to help
become help men become a better man in
all aspects of their life because that
carries over to other areas of the life
you know if you're if you you know for
example if your goal in life is to find
a girlfriend for example right that's
what you want to do well you shouldn't
really make your focus in life just like
going to bars and like trying these
lines and like doing these little
techniques what you should be doing is
just developing yourself as a man
physically you know working on your
social skills in general that are
applicable not just to women but also to
men and that women will find you
attractive once you kind of develop the
whole man and so yeah that's sort of our
philosophies just develop the whole man
and good things will happen as a
consequence of that in a nutshell if you
have to leave people right with this the
Brett McKay the soundbite that Oprah
would love I love that with Oprah
doesn't matter what you say we've just
done
forty minute interviews they can have a
soundbite that's going to work good for
the break what is it what would you say
it is to be a man and how does Art of
Manliness help with that to be a man
means being virtuous and by that I mean
the Roman Greek ideal of being excellent
in all aspects of your life and the Art
of Manliness all our content is geared
towards that and helping men strive for
excellence in their life in all aspects
that's there there's your soundbite
there you have it
Bret McKay's excellent adventure Art of
Manliness hey Bret we appreciate your
brother and hopefully you come back on
and you can educate hopefully we have
fun dip on next time he's not on right
now because fun dip is a producer who
okay you'll you'll see him if you peruse
the channel he's a he's a character and
he needs to a good kick in the pants to
become a better man sometimes he'll just
complain about I don't have time for
this I gotta eat my Hebrew National
hotdog breakfast he's a character that's
good it is delicious actually it's not
that if you think about it he justifies
it superbly if you're eating bacon
you're basically eating processed meat
he's just replacing it for a different
form of the hebrew national hot dog i
like a style look you and fun dip up
thank you so much Brett for coming on
brother thanks dear it's been a pleasure
if you like this video be sure to
subscribe or see my latest videos and if
you don't I'll be upset and trust me you
haven't seen me very upset